one man down you know you know things
are going bad when the only good news is
coming out of North Korea
according to Trump this week though is
one you will be telling your
grandchildren about because three Korean
Americans who you never heard of and
didn't know we're gone are safely home
ladies and gentlemen and Trump method be
upward at 2:00 a.m. did you see that out
in the dark and he was a very thankless
and thank you would like to thank him
who really was excellent to these three
incredible but really excellent he took
them hostage and forced them into a
labor camp what we here call an Amazon
warehouse
Kanye tweeted today they only thought
they were slaves
North Korea's in your mind that's but it
was actually easier to get them back
then we thought they wrote a check to
Michael Cohen good to go but now we had
now they're famous very famous in fact
two of them have already been me too
Wow oh you heard meatsuit got another
big fish Eric Schneiderman you know this
guy is he was big liberal hero he was
the Attorney General in New York on
after Trump champion and me too accused
by for women of violent physical abuse
this one took everybody by surprise
even the me two folks were like you two
and his excuse was he was role-playing
yes that's every woman's dream isn't it
I'll be Tina Turner you bi I'd say I
spent it this I said this is this is the
one area where we have bipartisanship
misogyny really the big political news
this week is that trumps amateur lawyer
Michael Collins had a slush fund where
he would take money in from people who
wanted access to Trump like AT&T and
pharmaceutical companies and the
Russians and then pay the money out to
people Trump [ __ ] at a golf tournament
I've heard of a rainy day fund this is a
stormy day fund
this michael cohen is such a bad lawyer
his jewish mother called him today and
said michael why couldn't you have grown
up to be a lawyer
[Applause]
the name of this slush fund was
essential consultants I love this
essential consultants there was only one
of them they were an essential and they
did no consulting and their slogan was
there are some things money can't buy
the president is not one of them the big
story the sad news is that Trump pulled
out of the Iran nuclear deal I'm sure
you heard this here's who wanted to stay
in the deal his defense secretary
general mattis his old national security
adviser McMaster 63% of the American
public the Republican head of the Armed
Services Committee all our NATO allies
the UN Security Council 94% of the
experts on Foreign Relations here's who
wanted to leave the deal and that's
America under so already
already Iran and Israel have traded
missile fire and Iran says they are
going to restart their nuclear program
on an industrial scale so that concludes
tonight's episode of the art of the deal
Kim jong-un must be saying tell me again
why I'm meeting with this clown so
Iranian lawmakers in Parliament this
never happened in their Parliament
yesterday burn the American flag and
were chanting death to America death to
America and Republicans here were
chanting already on it
already on it
that's all Trump does is pull out a [ __ ]
if he was a game show host it would be
called No Deal wait he wasn't gay [ __ ]
oh we screwed but no why did he pull out
because of his obsession of course with
undoing everything Obama did if he could
bring bin Laden back to life he would do
it he hated this Iran deal he said he
was sick and tired of foreigners not
fulfilling their end of the bargain but
enough about my sex life with Melania